et ça fait ça fait un mois et demi genre
un mois et demi que j'ai pas fait de
vidéos truc de fou hein pourquoi pas
parce que beaucoup de boulot beaucoup de
boulot mais ben je ne vous oublie pas je
vous oublie pas il ya plein de choses
le mec il se pointe un mois et demi
après tranquille tu vois ce rien pas de
vidéo pendant un mois et demi
voilà voilà voilà mais je vous ai pas
oublié aujourd'hui je vous donnais un
truc un truc mais trop bien pour faire
du montage et vous allez voir c'est
c'est simple ça va faire gagner du temps
et c'est après l'intro voilà
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore une chaîne sur la vidéo sur le
montage sur le tournage donc si c'est un
sujet qui vous intéresse je vous
encourage à cliquer sur le petit bouton
s'abonner la cloche tout ça ma chambre
je leur dirai en fin de vidéo et on a
donc passé un record sur la chaîne le
record de la plus longue période sans
aucune vidéo un mois et demi champion
voila voila c'est tu vois le truc qu'il
faut pas faire sur youtube dans te dis
pour publier régulièrement et tout mais
non françois ils écoutent pas tu vois si
c'est ce qui veut tout tranquille non
c'est juste qu'en fait j'ai eu
énormément de pro d2 de tournage pendant
l'été de montage aussi voulait sûrement
vu si vous me suivez sur instagram parce
que moi je prend quand même le temps de
faire des story donc
suivez moi sur instance ça permettra de
ce pour un petit peu plus souvent un peu
plus régulièrement et je sais que je
vous avais promis une formation qui
sortira bientôt un elle n'est pas passée
à la trappe c'est juste que j'ai du lala
délayé un petit peu je me suis donc dit
que j'allais vous faire une petite vidéo
bonus cadeau ça fait plaisir d'un
extrait en fait de cette formation d'un
sujet qu'on va aborder dans cette
formation justement qui va vous
permettre de gagner beaucoup de temps
sur vos montages et cette technique que
je vous partage c'est tout simplement ma
technique de des recherches par le
décrochage pour ceux qui savent pas ce
que c'est bas tout simplement c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a importé ces fichiers
vidéo après un tournage mais il faut les
trier on appelle ça le décrochage
on va choisir les morceaux en fait qui
nous intéresse dans notre montage et ses
longues quoi selon le shérif c'est la
pire partie en fait du montage des
recherches on va pas se mentir c'est le
truc le plus chiant et le plus naze mais
c'est indispensable
eh bien le faire c'est hyper important
si on veut avoir un bon résultat alors
faut savoir que chacun a ses petites
techniques 1 pour dérocher pour être à
l'aise pour ne rien louper
mais moi je vous donner la mienne
aujourd'hui et c'est une technique qui à
mon sens respecte tout à fait la
philosophie de fine gueule parce que ben
on déroge pas forcément sur final cut
common dérangerait sur première c'est
pas la meilleure façon de voir les
choses sauf si on est obligé de passer
de l'un à l'autre et qu'on veut
pas perdre ses habitudes mais sur final
cut il ya des fonctions hyper
intéressantes qui permettent d'être
précis et d'aller vite donc on va voir
ça tout de suite je vous montre c'est
parti et bien sûr ce sera un sujet qui
sera beaucoup plus détaillée dans la
formation depuis qui s'inscrira dans une
formation complète alors on est un petit
peu décroché vous allez voir ça quand
même vous servir j'en suis persuadé
alors une fois qu'on a importé nos
fichiers on se retrouve avec le
visualiseur qui va se retrouver sur la
gauche de l'écran
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est de
garder la forme de vignettes on peut
aussi avoir une forme de liste comme sur
première mais ici les vignes a tellement
être vachement importante il faut savoir
qu'on peut avoir une vue un peu plus ou
mais où une vue un peu plus réduite en
utilisant les raccourcis commandes plus
ou commandes - et dans ce visualiseur on
va venir sélectionner nos plans on va
pas prendre tous les plans et les mettre
dans la timeline ça ne sert strictement
à rien alors ses plans on va pouvoir
soit les lancers les lire directement en
cliquant dessus on a bien sûr la barre
espace mais on va pouvoir aussi scrollé
rapidement en passant dessus et voir le
rush en accéléré ça va nous permettre de
définir dans ce plan qu'elle est le
début qu'elle est la fin quel est le
morceau qui nous intéresse
une fois que j'ai défini le début de mon
plan là c'est tout simple je vais
appuyer sur la touche y pour définir un
point d'entrée un i come in poynt et
ensuite à la fin du morceau du rush qui
m'intéresse je vais appuyer sur la
touche au come out poynt un point
d'entrée point de sortie ensuite je peux
tout simplement vérifier qui a pas de
couille dans le potage sur la partie que
j'ai sélectionné et si elle me convient
je vais appuyer la touche f pour la
mettre en favoris et vous pouvez
constater que cette partie là aura un
petit liseré vert sur le dessus pour
indiquer que ce morceau est favori et
ensuite et ensuite mais ensuite moi je
vais répéter l'opération sur tous mes
plans en les scrollant rapidement ça
permet d'aller beaucoup plus vite de
voir si le plan est intéressant s'il
n'est pas louper et de prendre juste le
petit bout le i le haut le f
le hic pour le point d'entrée le haut
pour le point de sortie le f pour mettre
en favoris puisque c'est un plan combo
guard et technique que j'appelle
régulièrement et trivialement la
technique du yoff
heureusement qu'ils avaient pas un
raccourci avec un n quelque part sinon
c'est vrai c'est un truc un peu
pas terrible jha le calembour était
pourri sur une fois que j'ai trié tous
les plans que j'ai vraiment mis en
favoris tous les plans que je voulais
utiliser
je vais aller cliquer juste au dessus
sur tous les plans et c'est là que la
magie va opérer ici on va pouvoir
sélectionner uniquement certains blancs
fonction des rôles qu'on leur a donné et
je vous le donne en mille il ya bien
entendu les favoris je vais donc cliquer
sur favori màj dans le visualiseur ne
s'afficheront que les plans que vous
avez déjà des rochers les plans que vous
avez sélectionné les plans que vous
voulez finalement gardé un petit comme
en a pour tous les sélectionnés un petit
e pour tous les mettre directement dans
la timeline et votre dérochage est
terminée voilà c'est une pas plus
compliqué que ça et ça permet tu vois de
voir un petit peu tous les les plans
déjà de les tester avant et ne pas avoir
à tout découpé après dans la timeline à
faire un autre projet ou quoi que ce
soit il ne vous restera donc plus qu'à
va faire votre montage tout simplement
vous pouvez éventuellement rattraper des
petits rognage du dérochage s'il y avait
des petits bouts qui fonctionnait pas
déplacés en fonction de la temporalité
de ce que vous voulez mettre de
l'histoire que vous voulez raconter mais
au final bas le décrochage
il est terminé et il aura pas pris non
plus un temps monstrueux et puis voilà
et c'est aussi simple que ça voilà pour
cette petite vidéo les amis j'espère que
ça vous aura aidé j'espère que ça vous
faire gagner du temps dans vos des
recherches dans vos montages dans votre
création de films a bien sûr c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant d'utiliser ça
quand on a quand même un certain nombre
de plans si jamais vous avez deux ou
trois plans c'est pas forcément
intéressant mais dès qu'on commence à en
avoir une cinquantaine une centaine 200
300 400 je suis en train de penser à
tout le montage qui me reste à faire en
fait voilà ça va bien de servir de
techniques là heureusement qu'elle est
là c'est donc tout pour aujourd'hui les
amis je plaisantais au début sur le fait
de ne pas être régulier mais je vous
remercie encore une fois d'être fidèle
malgré ce petit voilà les cette rareté
et de vidéos mais sur un star il ya pas
mal de choses qui s'y passe fait les
petites story je vais essayer d'en faire
un petit peu plus avec marie on va
essayer de vous faire des trucs assez
sympa sur le sur instagram et puis la
formation arrivera un je vous dirais
franchement ça va arriver
allez un ou deux mois grand maximum et
d'ici un mois je pense que ça devrait
rebond y aura plein plein de choses donc
ne désespérez pas elle va sortir n'y a
pas de soucis vous inquiétez pas
d'ailleurs si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
il est toujours l'un le coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste
en dessous de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
également à vous abonner si c'est pas
déjà fait activer la cloche partagé la
vidéo commentée donnez moi vos avis vos
méthodes de l'eren et puis et puis voilà
bah moi je vous dis chose que je vous
avais pas dit depuis hyper longtemps
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
ça m'avait manqué quand même de faire un
petit peu de youtube
la cc c'est plutôt cool ça ça a été le
speed tout l'été la un truc de doubler
de taille je crois que j'en suis à 50
prod sur l'année mais un truc de malade
r je comprends pas les gens qui sortent
des vidéos il perd souvent et qui disent
qu'ils sont vides et assez qu'ils ont
plein de clients ce que je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'ils bossent pour leurs
clients en fait c'est chaud ou alors tu
es une équipe de plein de gens et
j'aimerais bien ça serait cool c'est
rare